obrigado tornou agradece imenso convite
a alguns de vocês já foram meus alunos e
e e é um prazer e uma grande honra estar
aqui é pra falar sobre a dar um elogio à
ideologia física porque há uma ideia
errada de que a ciência é premente a
objetiva racional e que é portanto
outros fatores não entrou em jogo né
e é isso que eu pretendo mostrar de
forma sucinta que não é bem cuidado né
a ci é uma obra dos homens e portanto a
sofre de todos os efeitos é que o homem
tem e é de facto o quando fala de
ideologia fala se uma criança né e essas
crenças estão de facto na ciência desde
o início na proficiência é pessoa numa
forma mística e foi evoluindo é pra se
tornar é uma coisa mais séria é como a
linguagem matemática e segundo a
definição de ciência do carro pop é o
que defino o fato uma disciplina
científica é a possibilidade de s verdes
falsificar é essa teoria aí toda a
teoria que que não cumpre os critérios
formas de quebrar é uma ciência é nós
vivemos num mundo que é infelizmente uma
civilização que está um pouco à deriva
não é e em grande parte é eu comecei a
considerar o porquê da situação um caso
do dramático em que vivemos e e
encontrou para se dizer três
responsáveis não são responsáveis mas
são três gigantes intelectuais que por
assim dizer justificam não é r
justificam o piauí o português com eles
com essas teorias nacionalizar o que
está aí né eu saí por cento os
responsáveis na que são gigantes e
intelectuais é
00 isaac newton adam smith da economia e
o davi né para fipe o dia né é
curiosamente o único tom e alan do facto
com as suas três leis da física que
vocês todos conhecem é faz parte da
cultura geral lã e ela é com aquele
espírito rigor que o atendeu transmitirá
a ciência eo facto de as regras para a
ciência é atual não é e será
extremamente disciplinada criteriosa
sistemática é eu depois foi copiado por
grandes economistas não entre os quais o
da mídia e na economia é e e depois pelo
davi também né
agora acontece que essas idéias têm sido
usadas de uma forma abusiva a a a meu
ver e isto porque é de facto também o
próprio nilton ano confirmou a sua
teoria também proporcionou isso é e eu
que se vê por exemplo a economia é de
facto é uma situação em que o fator
humano foi completamente esquecido né
a turma foi completamente esquecido e é
o que está portanto aí é um por cento o
mercado de trabalho não é palavra que se
usa o mercado de trabalho e em vez de a
economia estar ao serviço da fim do ser
humano não está de facto ser humano ao
serviço da economia e quando se fala no
mercado trabalho na verdade a idéia é
transmitir aqui também nós passamos a
ser uma mercadoria nós temos o zé é uma
mercadoria num disponível para ser usada
até à exaustão
é o darwin do outro lado foi aquilo que
pela primeira vez que introduziu a idéia
na ciência é a idéia portanto a relação
de troca pela primeira vez expulsava
irei a deus como o arquiteto ou designer
né
tudo isto é mexe estas idéias que depois
os outros seguiram baseados no
é na realidade do do nilton foi de facto
o seguir um caminho perigoso porque o
que se vê hoje é que é toda a gente diz
que é um chefe da oposição a um gesto
população e portanto é se você não sabe
bem a uma certa
portanto o combate à inflação e atento
uma faca tanto oposição a que mora do
fome no mundo e é miséria e miséria
enorme e nós temos de facto uma pequena
percentagem da humanidade que é
privilegiada é problema meu parte está
numa situação dramática né
essas idéias portanto tenha sido
perigosamento introduzir as profecias e
um feedback né ea ciência é começou a
seguir um percurso ciência e tecnologia
que é meu ver é perigoso é o caminho
perigoso e que nem é tão perigoso que é
eu fiquei sinceramente preocupado às
vezes até digo ajuda luddy confessa
preocupação porque na realidade a talvez
até a ideia civilização tenha sido um
erro é e por que não iniciar nós vamos
pensar fora da caixa e foram de caixa é
pensar será que a seleção foi um erro
por ter sido um erro né é a seleção com
sua invenção da agricultura mexe
vejam só quando com sua cibernética
portanto as perspectivas teve uma
unidade era que é de facto os robôs
iriam trabalhar pra nós
robôs devia trabalhar pra nós e nós
teremos tempo livre para o entre o
pioneirismo para é pra andar por aí pelo
mundo não é pra de facto gozar a vida
não é usar a vida que ninguém sabe o que
é uma coisa misteriosa mas o que nós
vemos hoje é uma situação perigosa que
quiser hádrons eu trabalhei em grandes
com o nos estados unidos com um dos
pioneiros dos trombos que aliás foi
preso pela pm caso da do professor do
professor nos estados unidos que foi
preso não é porque eu trabalhava a
importante função após ver como eu
também trabalho e então eu fui preso e
acusado pelo fbi e pelo ministério
público por passar segredos com um dos
segredos para tirar comunista né como se
este fosse comunista é de modo algum a
china comunista né
a china tem apenas o partido comunista
de facto fazer um trabalho
extraordinário para manter aquele país
enorme é funcionário de uma forma que
não é caótica e e estes drones agora né
e os cientistas que trabalham debaixo
desta ideologia extremamente liberal que
está aqui então é essa que podem decidir
por eles próprios no seu computador de
bordo se pode matar vocês vou matar ou
não alguém já no menor decisão humana é
os drums e serão os robôs que é portanto
com a dedicação o fim dos estudantes e
dos instigadores dos cientistas
estou a trabalhar para desenvolver a
inteligência dessas máquinas de uma
forma da univel estranhamente mais
elevado que o ser humano comunicando
pela cloud tal forma que um dia eles
próprios vão ver que nós burros netão
dizer é perturbar a vida deles porque
eles podem reconstruir seus outros né eu
vou fazer isso né e não precisaram nós
prêmio nobel é nada
e então aí e então aí eles vão destruir
e nós aí percebemos que a seleção possa
ter sido um erro né
tudo isto acompanhado também com uma
ideia também no youtube e ana de que é o
fato de que de facto este universo este
mundo dos corpos material pode
descontrolar pode ser para dizer é certa
uma idéia errada então tem deslavada
aqui é um mundo em que agora aparece a
biologia sintética a biologia sintética
acho que entre eles que nunca ela julga
estranhas tv e é chamadas matas
bush pistas a ciência não é que nós
provamos e tecnologia que deveria
construir de fato qualquer coisa do
humano assentou que é bom de escola o
casal que vocês quiserem pode colocar lá
é no robusto e vão saber o que vocês
pensam
posso colocar lá bactérias adormecidas
está tudo nesta tudo no google de facto
isso é uma coisa extraordinária que a
seleção produziu né que podem ser
ativados por sinais eletromagnéticos
nós vamos aspiramos spock caindo quem
traiu por exemplo há um caso estudado e
até com uma publicação científica que
podem ver na internet e comprovado que
lançaram poeira é só uma tela cidade
indiana em assumir as pessoas por
estoque e então se marque desta vocês
podem também ver né
podem colocar quiserem nós absorvemos
fica adormecido e quando nos quiserem
matar porque estamos há mais por que
filmar altos e o darwin que não lhes
eram mas enfim quis ssrs ideologia então
nós podemos de facto o mote é esta estas
idéias perigosas que hoje continuam aí
porque abre o caminho o turismo é
turismo é marco extremamente conveniente
né pra manter para manter o o o terror
sobre as sociedades né o terror imposta
por terminadas elite ol o grupo de
pessoas completamente a lógica não é bom
eu ando na espanha mecânica porque idéia
de facto que queria era chegar aqui né
era ela chegará ao nilton eu comecei a
pensar que há de facto aquela idéia da
força externa é igual à massa vez a
floração que vocês aprendam a escola eo
ensino aos meus alunos
essa ideia é uma idéia perigosa né
porque essa ideia perigosa porque é essa
ideia perigosa e só teve algumas coisas
que esta craque né porque esta ideia diz
que há uma força externa externa que a
gente só no sistema um corpo vosso
descrevia completamente
vocês ficam com uma exploração com uma
velocidade de escrever
o movimento que uma força externa ao
qual vocês estão submetido é palavra que
a gente põe os exercícios os alunos não
é isto é perigoso não é isso é perigoso
e esta ideia de que é possível uma força
externa de forma impune dominar o ser
humano é errada e eu é de certa forma
acho que contribuí para isso porque é é
e 2013
publiquei um artigo numa grande revista
que é do grupo de repórteres vocês todos
podem ver um dinheirão para que estará
acessível ao público no bolso
e então o que eu mostrei o que eu
mostrei que o nilton eu não tinha
hipótese eu não tenho hipótese
descartada leito no tempo do nilton a
termodinâmica não estava envolvida com o
trabalho do canudo clausi introduzir o
conceito novo de entropia o nilton não
conhecia portanto eu nunca podia chegar
a isso e então ah ah ah como nilton
havia era uma maneira de ligar é um
movimento geral no universo que
é constituído por uma translação e uma
mutação resolvendo de forma independente
a equação para translação que esta
equação para a votação que acha que a
partida aliás e e eu nunca discuti bem
que é de fato escreveu isto é uma
espécie foi o nilton mas não chove no
norte como histórias não consigo
encontrar mas o o o que eu fiz nesse
trabalho é que é bom
é um conceito novo né que foi
introduzida no nosso caminho que é o da
entropia né então todos os fenômenos que
ocorrem no universo nestas aula dentro
do nosso corpo
resulta essencialmente de um balanço
entre o dois conceitos distintos que é o
de energia e dentro pia ea uma qualidade
e uma luta é uma luta no sentido como há
hoje que é tudo agressivo tudo salvagem
né é um equilíbrio não é entre as duas e
energia tempo mínimo entropia o máximo e
quando o povo se isto num princípio
direcional eu descobri que há a lei do
movimento não é aquela porque aquela é
igual ao mma como vocês não sabem tem
que ser resolvida com o outro tal igual
à de alguém te depois juntas no fim não
há uma equação que esta aqui esta que
esta junta os dois eo depois comecei eu
duvidei que falei tá fora o trabalho né
porque prontas em direito só enfiar só
os nilton de coisas podem chegar a
coisas assim que têm utilidade
comunidade né então eu apliquei está os
nossos problemas netter que eu dou aos
meus alunos e mecânica e um novo e vocês
podem resolver-se depois começarem é
consultar o trabalho qualquer problema
de mecânica com esta acção integrada não
é eu escreveu o atleta escreveu o livro
já fiz uma proposta também uma grande
vitória que irá analisar se é possível
fez o interessado não publicar o
trabalho mas o que que esta equação
disso essa discussão já não diz que nós
estamos sujeitos uma força externa ele
diz que a possibilidade do sistema
controlará deviar se contornar os
obstáculos
eu estou ingrediente é uma taxa de
seleção especial de energia de lotação
que todos os corpos têm talvez por isso
é que os de serviços né
portanto não te perseguiram e tudo está
encontrar deus encontrar deus não só de
nós e não se expor dessa pra casa
esquecendo por resolver e desde então
encontra a deus né
é esta nova visão de tudo na natureza no
fundo resulta do de um balanço do
movimento de translação e rotação e
rotação nem relatos de tornados por
exemplo são uma tentativa da natureza de
encontrar o equilíbrio né
mas é uma tentativa de fugir também em
frente externos né é um dom como o o o
atleta do parkour também quando falta do
andar à roda são parte o sócio é e é
este é essa nova visão foi uma uma
tentativa minha de voltar a dar a
ciência é uma perspectiva que aquela que
deve ser paciência né
a dengue é encontrar um equilíbrio e
voltar a dar à humanidade um
investimento um investimento em que a
palavra humana e uma mirada você está
presente não é que se esteja a serviço
da sociedade e das pessoas
toya tudo o que tem a dizer
[Aplausos]